hello to all thank you for your presence
my name is clement because I am
a customer engineer at google
I am pleased to have my side sopra
steria who comes to support my presentation
to share his experience and
illustrate this session on
data modeling
here at google we used to
say this and i think it makes perfect
sense today i'm
uncomfortably excited by this
excited crowd because you
small medium and large businesses are looking
to accomplish and how technology
can help you
a  your concerns the use
of data to improve your business
a vast subject before getting to the
heart of the matter giving you a
demonstration of how to set up a
streaming data pipe line
in 5 lines of code on a
chrome browser and  make a query on a
billion lines I would still like to
come back to the fundamentals
that we have faced in our
job at google to  our products the
years of r&d that we devoted to them
and the organization to be put in place to
succeed with that gave then we will
start with a bit of history
digues marc the
german encryption machine reputed to be
inviolable
if you have seen the film imitation game
where the limitation game in quebec
according to wikipedia you have already seen this
machine for what they have not seen
here i make it short
alan decrypts  enigma three
important things to remember in this movie the
genius is not in the machine the
machine is a useful second
thing
alan turing spent 90% of the time
breaking what we see in the movie
putting this machine in place  what
between us I find quite sad and the
third thing
this very sophisticated machine at
the time made it
possible to test thousands
of recordings and combinations in
24 hours we will change  ger of scale and we are
going to talk about google's mission google's
mission is to organize
global information to make it
accessible and useful to all besides
the origin of the name google for those who
still believe in  the vague history of
binoculars actually refers to the
mathematical terms google which designates
a number starting with one is followed by
100 0 10 to the power of 100 beyond the
volumetrics to process
google's mission is not an easy task
is what  we seek to do is to
make this information accessible and
useful to everyone everywhere and all the
time
and this dna this mission we try
to include it in all of our
products and I believe that be curry is
really a  good example of this mission
has been set so I'm going to give you
two figures on our
search engine one billion
you must have seen it in others
in other presentations this is the number
of users today that  we have on
our search engine  che 100 billion
it is the number of requests today
that ensures our search engine
and it is not just a keyword that we
recover it is a set
of information that allows us
to analyze and better  actually understanding
what is happening on our research
what we are really trying to do has
improved and makes it
more relevant every day the technical problem
behind it and I was saying that is what
the machine will solve it  is how to
analyze this volume of data
so a few years ago a little
over ten years ago we
engineers started working on a first
system where we tried to analyze
massively with parallel processing
give it you have certainly
heard of  of google fs is even more of
mapreduce it is moreover a
publication in 2004 which gave
birth to the elephant that many
people know in the hadoop room
yes except that very quickly in fact this
system it turned out to be very  s difficult to
maintain
very difficult and what it is and it
was not really accessible that is to
say that today to make hadoop
you have to speak hadoop so our
engineers got back to work and
I will  put a little suspense on the
new system that we released and which
gave birth to bidegorry to come back
and I insist the genius is not in the
machine and I propose to you to lay the
foundations of data modeling and
it is based on a first thing that is
mastered indulge today in
companies
what we see the most is people who
want to go fast that they want to
collect to give it and when we
ask them a simple question  but what
do you have the right to do with your
data how are
you organizing it who is in charge of
recovering it and we find ourselves in an
impasse
so today we see companies
and this person who  represents this
data entity in the company  made the front
page of harvard business review he
is the chief data officer the sponsor
she is the spokesperson for data for
the company so he is not alone he
has data lockers who know the
laws on the exploitation of the give
dates to remember or data managers they
have two names but it is the same ones who
organize the deal and who only know
the business needs and who tell themselves
what we are going to recover as a priority
and then the data will be a  track
who do either data analysis
or modeling with machine
learning and moreover we have
solutions that help our customers to
put erding machine models in
place and finally and I think that's the
role  of everyone in the company is
that each of you must be a data
storyteller, that is to say that today
the deal and that you exploit you
must make sure to make it available for
sale to your company to return
this  accessible information and
communicate your successes  sites but also
on your failures and this is the second
part of the importance in the
modeling of giving it apart from the
machine it is
failure failure this is what we find when we
try to analyze a  problem when we
try to analyze a problem the
first thing we do is
collect the data and we have seen there are
plenty of solutions to collect
structured and unstructured data
or even images from videos
then we assume it  is to say that we
make assumptions about this problem
and most of the time we are wrong
so try not to avoid being
wrong it is a very
French model to have the perfect copy is
then to launch this  what we're trying to
do is get it wrong as
quickly as possible and the bigger the data
the slower the cycle so
what we're trying to do at google
is put systems in place
that allow you to  'fail
faster today at google when
we do innovation  we and that's
the essence of innovation it
's trying to set up systems set
up projects and allow yourself to
kill them just as quickly if it
doesn't work and that's really
google's dna  that is to say it is
inscribed in all our
human resources it is to say if I want to set
up a project I must have the
capacity but I must also be able to
have the capacity to stop it the
next day so not  as long as we have talked about
the two fundamentals around data
and that essentially concerns
the organization and dissemination of
data in your company
we will rely on technologies
to execute queries
when we will have a technology we say
I  I'm going to execute queries as
quickly as possible and what we try
to do at google is not
to execute queries,
it's to model getting the wrong euros, to
model to make assumptions and
to act and that  is really what's
behind big quarry that's where i
finally going to come back to the work that
was done by our engineers to
succeed in putting such a system in place
the principle
a publication as always at
google in 2010 on dremel dremel what is
it we open the hood a little
it  is thousands of servers that these
are things that we have available
then it is a
column database that is to say that today we
do not organize the data earlier in a
database in  line and we
realized that it was not at all
optimal and therefore to optimize the
scans to paralyze the processing and
to optimize the compression of the
data
we will organize this data in the form
of a column then it is a
multi storage  zone it was one of the problems
we had with hadoop this data had been separated,
that is to say we have
to put the deal is located where
there was our colorful heart machine
we realized  that it was not at
all effective in particular  his attempt to sky
leave the system there is the last thing
is that we realized that we
often saw them giving it flat in
his systems and that it was not
necessarily the ones we needed
above all  when we had logs to
analyze and it was to be problematic
to start with billions of logs and finally
the last thing in this concept of
dremel is to make it accessible to
everyone, that is to say that  you need a
particular language that nobody
knows to be able to make a
simple request on a system
the project was not viable so in
action what is an
analyst enough which is a very simple question
which consists here just in  count the
number of records per category in
paris if you try to set it
up in a system where the language is
proprietary or the language is complicated
it will be complicated for the analyst
on the other hand what is complicated is
what happens  spends a little more in
all pr  google products
it's when you go to our
search engine you type a
keyword in an interface that is very
simple and the magic works behind the
scenes and that's what also happens
on our big three
c' product  that is to say that to set up
this real mail publication, well,
you need distributed storage, you
need a petabyte network that
takes this data and distributes it
over work hours, you need a lot of
drama to be able to distribute it
by category and finally
you still need a network of free
tabate and other workers to aggregate
all this data this is really what
we tried to set up with
dremel and in 2011 we launched big three
and big pooh  eric is what it is is to
make accessible this publication which
was dremel that's why I
think it's really a good example is
that emails by don bigg quarry it's
a product that is  accessible from
any  navigator and with a
simple sql query it feels like a single
index can get up no server you
will be able to exploit your data and
that whether you have a few lines a
few hundred a few thousand
up to a few hundred
billion eu and all that without asking yourself  the
question of whether I need
to have more servers some
notions to understand with big three and
on the practices that you generally
use these one queries columns
is what we do not do especially on big
quarry it is  to go and do a select
stars to go and retrieve all
the columns do what happens which
will simply take all the
columns and scan them and then you
return 1000 rows for that we have planned
because it is a  functionality that we
use very often this little
command line of the star select is
simply to have a preview of the
table I will show you later
in the demonstration
then we have  separated the data by
column but we are also going to separate them
to consume less resources by
date and therefore it's called partitioning
by date, things that are fairly
standard but these are things that
must be used in be corrie to
scan the  less data possible
finally bic coheris is a solution that
you can feed up to 100,000
lines per second in real time to
perform live data analysis
some of our customers
sometimes use this feature to stream
and data and do  data transfer
if you stream and give it away
and it's a good practice try
to do it above all for a
business need we will send a concrete case later
2 why use
giving it away finally in terms of
performance  to use external tables
you will not exploit
all of what victory can do
is for you so load the
data in big three you are
used to making
rel models  ational and typically when we
do bia and when we do
data analysis and we
make this data available you have a whole
team that takes care of making
cubes to ensure that these cubes
turn the  weekend to distribute this
data is generally in these models
you have snowflake models where you
put your dimensions and the source tables
in any case large tables in the middle
of its snowflake architecture in big
three that's not how we see
things we really see there is
work to be done on the normalization
of the data and to tell ourselves that the data m
generally arrives in the form of a log and
that this is how we are going to analyze it
misfortune victory for the  companies
what is it we talked a lot about
the paper the publication we opened the
hood we talked about the story of the
date two of the number of machines we
had open bikkuri it's a
server solution  let's not worry about
my  chines no longer does this maintenance
just open a web browser and
you can go there it's competitive
when you design a solution to
manage payroll your data bite we have
to make a competitive solution in
terms of storage and in terms of  cost
and rice on its data to give you an
idea we are at $20 for soil to store
and $5 for rock land was if
you really need
unlimited racket we have prices that
are very advantageous for
companies
beyond that  we have a system that is
secured by 700 engineers everything
we do on google cloud is
fully secure integrate
integrated because in your
company you already have a nebula
of solutions that are in place for your
lease and for your analysis and big query
can  fully integrate into your
business and we have a multitude of
partnerships to name a
few with whom we work
IT at talend matignon and for
quote data
viewers we work with qlikview table
and others finally we said it's
something that must be accessible so you
can easily integrate into your
applications no victory there comes with
a sql language to query it  and you
can integrate it in the form of a country
in the form of libraries and therefore you
can integrate it into all your
python go java applications and you
always have leftovers if we don't have the
language you need.  saw it it's beh
and real time and accessible I
think it's really the word you have to
remember it's giving access to my data
in the company and it's done via a
simple web browser
we  going to take a basic use case
so I work as a
customer engineer in the retail industry so
it's always easier to talk about
cases that we know and that's
there later I  was referring to the genius
of machine panoramas but rather to
our  customers and I have cases that are
rather interesting where we illustrate a
little bit everything that I have just described to you
two simple questions of the trade how to
identify the products that are
missing in merrigan oms has
brought in hot
data data that is  in my meetings and
what I want to do is above all to act,
that is to say how am I going to
do to detect who has a frequency
of purchases typically at 5 p.m. in a
supermarket to tell themselves about this product
there  hasn't sold for ten minutes
I would have to alert
my store manager when you have a
store it's quite simple to set
up when you have hundreds
or thousands of them around the world
it starts to be more difficult to
analyze and  this is where you're going may
need a solution like big om
the second question is you've
all heard of contactless
i imagine you all use
it and it's like stake deploys it in my
shops  ins in order of priority
so we're going to assume for the exercise we
're just going to take the proportion of
baskets at less than 20 euros in a
city for the anatomy of a basket
I spoke to you earlier about the
structure of the data  and of the
normalizations it is typically done
to leave it as it is and if we take a
basket we have a date we have a customer we have
a city we have an income we are and
above all we have the contents of the basket it is
to say all the products that we
have that have been purchased and finally what
we find on our
receipt in a relational model
we will separate this information and we will
put our transactions on one side and the
detail  of these transactions
of products that have been purchased in
another table in big corrie you
will be able to do this on a single
line by nesting the data of your
transactions and the details of these
transactions
now I propose to set
up
in 5 lines of  code a system
real time to collect all the
data that suffers in our stores we
hear more and more about haiti
I think this use case essentially applies
to masses of data
that you want to recover a show and
yaute  there is a very good example of this
let's imagine today that your boxes
are connected objects for that what
we are going to put in place these we cannot
presuppose how many lines I will
accommodate in my table we said everything before
hour
bic could have accommodated up to 100
miles per second so to do
the analysis it's more than enough
it doesn't matter we're going to secure we're going to
make our architecture even more
robust by creating a queue of messages
that can accommodate  2 1
a billion messages no matter who is
called pop job
then we will use a product bone
called data flow which allows you to
manage apajh bim and apache bim it is
an open source library you will use for
free and which you  allows you to do
both the match and the
stream hence the name paju bim and once we
have dumped our data hot we
will analyze them in big white
so we might as well warn you we have already
talked about it I am subject  to the bonaldi effect and
I'm going to give you a demo so for
those who don't know jerome
bonaldi he was an animator from
nowhere else who presented
innovations and most of the time these
demonstrations failed miserably
I hope it won't  the case for me
today
[Applause]
so here I am in my cloud shell
the interest of working in the cloud
is above all not having to be on a
computer and the red game the father or the
day I  I'm stealing it from losing
all my work so here here I'm
really on my web browser and I
'm actually going to create all my architecture
from this browser
so the first thing I'm going to
do is I told you about advertising
this system  which allows you to create a  cloud
messaging so really a system that
can accommodate an unlimited number
of messages and that I'm going to do it in
a command line
here is my topic has just been created so
I just want to go and check then
that everything was fine  created just
for bonaldi facts the second thing
is that I'm going to create my table so it's
going to be called orders stream and the
third thing I'm going to do is
launch my dataflow so I'm actually relying on
a template  which can accommodate
any jeason so enter what
my application will ultimately generate and
which will distribute over a number of workers
that I have defined located in europe we
can see it here and more
particularly in belgium which will
distribute the information that  'they
recover from my topic to
dump them in my table so I
simply copied its lines and I'm going to
launch worker I have one last
thing to do is generate to give it
so what I did is  that  e i
wrote a little script that
randomly generates transactions with
cart detail and i'm trying to
make it do enough
for my demo to make sense and you
see how much using the  cloud
offers you an elasticity for you in
your company to
launch a job on q bern and
hoist so sure gkl google confirms jean emond jobs
has just been created and we are going to go and
check
while waiting for all that to start
that all of the things that  I created
are there so I find
my topic here which is ready to receive
messages my feed has just been created and
I'm just going to check for my table in
order to give you a complete demo and
I have my table  order stream which for
you and unpublished of the scheme we use
so I have date ghg city I have the type
I have the method of delivery the method of
payment
gd order heidi which are generated
randomly and I have the  detail of
my basket which are in what we
call  the one reee ropes and dance rekord
I will have all of my values
re repeated on the same line with the n
me lady of the product the name of the product the c
tegory in which it is located the p
ice at which we sold the quantity and the
total price and the brand to which it
belongs I'm going to go back now
to my data flow and we see here that
I welcome about five years 54
miles has gone down to 27000 because
in fact I made a buffer of one
buffer of my messages which are
directly partisan can and I'm
starting to slowly pour them
into big quarry finally very slowly it's
been running for about 10 seconds
and I have just sent
five hundred and seventy three thousand lines
to my table  so to show you
that this demo is not completely done
that it's not a video we're
going to make a first request that
I recorded here and it's called
stream true story
so what we're going to do on this  table
it's simply looking at the max and the
mine of the dates of my table
so there we can see it's the current
date and that I just have a small
time difference and the 2:23 p.m. but it's normal
I think that the  miss h I'm going to
raise and I think it's just my
time zone which is not good now
and that's what I'm going to do here we're going to
count the number of rows we have
just received in this table just to
show you what the system has already
sent
so we are already almost a million
lines and
I have been talking to you for forty seconds imagine if you put this
in your company you will be able to
recover in real time and in 5 lines
of code
as promised  all of your
transactions and that's not enough I
want a lot more so I'm going to scale and
my system
while waiting for it to calm down with my
applications launching
I now suggest you see on
a table partition and I'm going to
show you  in big quarry a preview  of
this table we can clearly see here
giving it and normalized i.e.
we have both the detail and sorry
both the aggregate and the detail in my
table in this table I have to  about
million orders so transactions in fact it
represents a lot more lines and I
will see it but we will see how many lines it
represents while waiting for a
second request that I have recorded
and looking at all of  my
period the total number of rows
so there we have about a little over a
billion products
in my table and we have just executed a
query that took less than six seconds
and that has a trial  is 37 gigas of
data
regardless of what you are
going to put in big quarry it will
always manage to make
the most optimal execution plan for
you to return the result in a few
seconds or even in a few minutes
if you trial it  Is lands or
firecrackers given I was talking to you all  at
the time of the normalizations but
in some cases you will have to
denormalize the normalize the give it
because your dimension tables change
very often you can
anyway do in big three and I
save you another quest which
shows exactly this  example and which is
called footwear transaction if you
have done a little data analysis if
you have already done a little sql you
will recognize
in fact we use a very simple sql query
will I go and
look here  this is the category of my
product at level zero and i would like to
search in fact all that is
footwear
again in a few seconds
i still have a lawsuit it is about
fifty giga and i did not
ask myself the question of how much  machines
i needed is how many
machines i reinstalled
i just gave me a sql query a
result
so we did a lot of sql queries
but not everyone talks about sql and now
nant must distribute the data in
the companies so I will take
another two minutes after I will
give the floor to sopra steria to
show you what we can do with a
product that we make available to our
customers called data  studio which is
completely free today and which
allows you to make dashboards available in
your company in
a very simple way is even simpler
what we usually do, that is to
say that here I did not bother to
do  cubes
I'm not bothered to pre trial
gave me to the aggregate to make it
available
in fact I just got more cheerful at my
table and I'm able to analyze these
few billion products in
real time and I  am going to show you just a
little sorting for example if I tell him I
would like to have
that card payments
we are analyzing a table which
really represents a billion
products there are about ten strokes and
rice to arrive at the  displayed all these
results and we will see that in a few
seconds the
world album will be
completely updated we hope we hope so here we
see on this dashboard that for all
card payments
we had peaks for the balances we in
paris  which makes the most revenue
but paris is not the best performer
the best performer and lyon
for card payments
so the example I chose there is
not super relevant but it just shows you
when a few lines of code give you
can put in the cloud
a system that allows you to host
hot give it give it
on billions of requests and that without
having asked anyone
how many servers and you needed and
without having waited six months to
set up this  project and we come back to the
initial problem it is not 90%
of your time that you will spend on
the implementation of a solution it is
90% of your time that you will spend
to analyze your problems I will  is
now give the floor to sopra
steria to present what they are
actually doing with our customers to organize
data in companies
from this month we can change
so before that happens I
scroll g hello at all times  and
whips guenane I'm what we call
a geek step so since a while ago
we've been talking about byd co and laughing we're talking about a
lot of things and thank you lenient
by the way if you can and
applaud them I think they  were super
awesome
so I'm going to talk to you
about organization I'm going to talk to you about
values data as you've seen we can a
ways exploit it but do we pu
value behind it before talki
g about that I  I'll still present
bing
maps what is bing maps we are a
consulting firm specializing in the cloud
but who says consulting firm says a
lot of advice
it's a bit wrong in and 25 people
but we are divided into two large
families  cloud architects and  are
cloud consultants because we think that
in the cloud
there is technology there is also the way of
doing things and all that must be
complementary
so what happens is that I
haven't given you a bit of our offers which are
summarized  there since I think that we have to
be speed and that we have to finish at 5
p.m. anyway
is what we do is that we do
the cloud but also security have
done change support
we do compliance and of course in
touch with new technologies the
question is not there I'm going to talk
I'm going to talk to you about concrete cases
when we arrive at a client
when we arrive in the client's IT department and
well everyone  is like that they
discovered a new technology and are
all crazy about this technology and behind it you
have to roll out a plan to deploy it
and put it in place for the trades
and all the techno on board are like that the
dsi masters
on the other hand when the client  the customer finally arrives,
it's the job  went
like this it happens
well well it's like that it's a bit like the
mechanic who makes a car but who
hasn't put the options stuck we
find ourselves a little unsatisfied us to
avoid that we support our customers from
the start  and we take everyone and
here is our method creates value
through techno that means what
we get we are not a big
team tumbling in two or three we observe
and we understand what we want
understand what do you want to
do with this techno
ladies and gentlemen
what do you want to do with it to whom
you want to offer it platform data
platform tools blocks chain but
behind wanted to do what with the use
and so we manage to  to ask these
questions and to define together not only
the dsi not only the professions but all
together the use the objectives and batteries
services that it is served what is
the added value that we want to do we
want to have that we want to offer it is
internally or  external
and then as soon as we have this plan we go there and
when I say we go there we are in
collaborative mode with all the trades
all the dsi like that we are not
in silo mode do not come out with a techno
that nobody  don't understand where we don't go out
with a technology that nobody uses
and we simply manage to measure
the maturity of users to adopt technology as
soon as we have that bing we know
that I have used it or not if it is
not  we have to define the why,
if it is, we have to speed up, we are
a generation that wants everything right
away, I think
everyone agrees, we are fed up with projects
that take a year or even six
months  two years and even too many and we want
everything right away
so if we want everything right away you
have to not arrive with a five-
year plan to arrive with a poc
to arrive with something
concrete you have to unfold it you have to
speed up and therefore snag  in all this we
may build something very
good, something ch  dare to be very beautiful
something very consistent but no
one comes to the store why because
we did not communicate on it very important axis
communicated on the value that we offer
today a lot of dsi do
not communicate the trades more  or less
but we see a lot of cloud projects a
lot of data platform data projects
that are running out of steam in the
first months why no one comes to
consume and therefore in this whole cycle
we have created a value that did not exist
in the  company
we were collaborative we were in
partnership mode with everyone
in india internally and externally and in the
end we resulted in value
we resulted in value-added services
and in the end we resulted in a good
result shared by all so here
I am making it short but I hope my
message
got through we help companies like
auchan retail we were talking about retail earlier
to set up their
data platform on 14  countries and I can
tell you that we have been collaborative with
the 14 countries with all the professions and
that is why it is starting to take
shape
I will come back I hope next year
to present you with a few more
results is  a lot more
material on this so thank you and I'll
pass the floor to pierre arnaud sorry
thank you fouad
so first of all hello pierre arnaud
I am a solutions architect at sopra
and steria
I would like to know among you who
does big data or servers  leave the hand
who among you only do big data
and the or the server leave that
nothing else so here it will start to
interest me because the data has a
value once we talked about it we must
try to  come out to
assert it and communicate on it but
the data does indeed come from somewhere to
give it you have to go get it the
deal and I follow the customers crowd
behind that it's with us I did
n't think the others are on
system  th production so the data is
an important value making sure that the
data will be able to arrive in your
big data systems it will be part
of our work
how we are going to do it first of all we
will have to work with you above all
we s  rely a lot on bima
to define the needs where is the
value who needs it and how to
present it we will help you prepare it
to do time to test and validate
failed start again quickly like
presenting it lenient and once  all
this is valid and the socra style is
coming we do the
workload emigration we take you from your
datacenter to google cloud platform
where we directly rework what
you have a little dough form to
ultimately operate a system have
availability  and ensure commitments
that will be identical to those you
have in the datacenter in google
cloud platform when you look a little
bit at the sting of what you
currently have  in datacenters I
think that quite a few of you
work in the datacenter or
nearby directly or indirectly
you know you have a lot
of skills resources that
require you to invest very
compartmentalized in silos you have
the network expert of  the
storage expert the backup expert
you have people who do
case management not what google platform will bring
it's a very strong concentration of
profiles so there actually at the level
of organizations bing maps au prince à
rien we tell you  helps a little bit with wurz
mashed stuff the main idea behind all that
is to say it finally when
you come to google platform you
will free up time time what
human time you have people
doing activities  on storage
who will necessarily have their job which
will
decrease moreover that must be your questions I
think if you are in the dsi or
dsi project what am I going to do
d  tomorrow of my age and networks of my
storage or
backup expert the opportunity is to
train him on big data technologies
to take him a little more towards
cloud technologies and to focus
on profiles that have  a strong
added value on this we also accompany you
sopra and steria to make big
eyes to train them to make your
own concepts as fouad said
you have to try to get out the value you
can be wrong
the advantage is that you are wrong  we redo
and very quickly we will have
iterative methods or arrive
at solutions that correspond to
everyone and especially to expectations and
markets to get there as I
said we have to start taking an interest
in people we talk about technology  we
talk about big data from big to
every intelligence is not in the
machine intelligence go to your
house internally
when we want to know if your data
has value the word grid in vain to
know  r is to ask those who are
in the business who know where the value is and
those they will need
so there we have to take an interest in
people assist them support them then we
will address the trial part what is it
that we will simply question
the way of design is
to bring new mechanisms we
were very oriented on constraints
related to the datacenter tomorrow these
constraints have exploded we will
focus on business applications
and also on security  to
conduct data is massively in the
cloud at google we will inevitably
ask ourselves the question of how
this data will be managed who will access it and
how will it be secured you know very
well that google platforms are
hyper secure we are talking about layers
low to accompany you on the
security of the high layers you
very often need to rely
on companies which are specialized
in this its prince narnia it is the case we
know t  very well get you to make the
right assumptions and above all make the
right technological choices to secure
your
nose and finally ensure that we
won't have cases like recently we
heard blocks are in which
keys are stored
encryption or passwords that
allows access to data this type
of error must absolutely be avoided
and finally and only finally we are going to be
interested in technology this is where
we will be able to really draw the essence
of  'a technology like big willie that we
will really have the value why
because this this information that we
have consolidated it comes from a
business need which is at the origin that of the
customer the one for whom we are there to
deliver services and  of course all
these elements, if we want them to make
sense, come from production data a little
while ago Clément talk to us about
data and retail
what are we selling in a store
like removing bank data  s in
particular because there are prices
behind there are consumer baskets
and personal data
we also process health data
we work a lot in the
banking world and of course all
this data we will have to ensure
that it  arrives on a continuous flow is
correct in no big data for that it's
very simple we stay on
standards of operations the operation
what is it in the end it is to know how to operate
types of services but to operate them in
a modern way  not
just operating them as we did before
in our datacenter
is knowing what we want to
operate we have types of services that
are specific others that have
remained standard all to their joy ya  of
course, we do server work, but that's
really the trend,
we still have resources that are
low, middleware, operating system,
data base, all of that, we're going to have to
operate on them, recognize them, make sure
that there are people who are capable  able
to provide continuous service on it you
will therefore associate service levels
when your very
critical data you want it to be
fed 24 hours a day in your big data you have to
make sure that they have people behind them
who can operate in  in the event of an anomaly
of incidents we can still have on our
infrastructures and in particular in the
club we will not do we are not yet
completely servers leave so we
can have quite simple saturations in
fact the system that we have seen we
needs people who will operate 24 hours a day
respond to requests
developments integrations
we will also have new uses
and ours our model the sopra
steria model is knowing how to
recognize elasticity unlike  other what
sopra steria is doing when we are
going to operate on your systems in production
is only to invoice the value on
our operations
the value to the east where to go where we
have concrete actions to carry out on
types of auto scaling of elasticity on
sql cloud or this type of technology
it is only the services on
which we are proposing to you to
invoice for in fine and also to have a
service which completely follows the
trend of the club
of  elsewhere operations at their desire
to say yes it's interesting but
we have systems that run 24 hours a
day in production it's not
just systems that run 24 hours a
day generally we run them a
little bit  out of spite because we do
n't want to stop them we have
systems that are there to do the
calculation they will do the calculation for
1h 2h a week but during this
week of calculation where they will inject
to give it precisely in the ebitda
time we don't want these systems to
stop, we want them to have people
who are behind them, who are proactive,
who in the event of an anomaly can act
and ensure that the calculation is
carried out to the end  we also have
platforms  training elms
training platforms that are not there
all year round we need a few hours a
few days a year what we are
offering you is to have, like a
google cloud platform, a service
of  'operation billed by the hour it is
you who
choose when you are going to have
operations when you are going
to stop them or simply
ask you to do it and there you will have a
follow-up so here is the
sopra offer and  steria summarized very quickly
we have an operation service in perfect
harmony with the club
is what we offer you is to
keep datacenter commitments what
we knew how to do a prime eyes
we did it even better  in the
google club last point i was talking to you about
operation what we also see
when we are often with the dsi the
dsi have good ideas wish to
offer applications served
quickly business us what we
offer you is  to put them in saas
o mode  We do it in banking, we do it
on health data on
health perimeters where we are able
to generate generations of
calculation farms in less than an hour with
service commitments behind that,
so thank you for listening
i invite you to come to the
sopra steria stand to see if you would like
live demos discuss with us
share what we have done
with other customers on this guy on the
packages on the saaS mode on the service
and  the operations thank you to all of us